yeah okay ladies and gentlemen you know
the singing Mike
but I always do karaoke
I love Carrie LOC I'm I'm mortified by
yeah so here's the thing like oh my god
is gonna give me the mic skydive I am
not afraid of heights I'm not afraid of
like spiders I'll look do like I've
caught first pitches we do stand it but
just carry however if you want to see me
get afraid ask me to sing and/or dance
like that's my phobia when it girls like
a hot girls like come on come dance what
does while I'm out there dance I'm just
going to you so still look like an idiot
I'm not uncomfortable and then and then
like you like I don't want to think I
don't want people to think that I think
I'm too cool yeah so I don't want to do
it too cool move so I'm trying to be
silly silly that's like man you're like
a dad and people are like and not to
mention it's it's a stereotype of white
people so like I'm like I'm reinforcing
the stereotype we can't dance look
what's happening everyone's gonna look
at that white [ __ ] that's what's
happening
okay well before we even keep going here
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
podcast
actually my longtime friend because even
when I remember when you first started I
was just starting myself I'd never do it
like rushing but I would ladies you're
welcome to the podcast mr. Jeff died
yeah thanks man
you know thanks for coming on I've
wanted you to come on for a while so
yeah you were in Seattle and I had okay
so I started and say 2003 okay that's
fine
and then right it was around 2004 and
five that I was doing like those
contests yeah
like I had done the the Salt Lake City
won I forgot which one that was called
the ya know the rocky Rock laughs oh
what a disaster I came in second place
because one night that they claimed oh
you could be you could say whatever you
want because it was in Utah so you had
to be clean right so there was just one
that did they go you don't have to be
clean but I know they held it against me
okay cuz you were like good anything
goes and they like he fell for our trap
yeah like I came in last place that day
really and and I still came in second in
the contest I just told you now
automatically proposed yes means you had
you had a clinch right I would have won
that it was then I had John this yeah
like if the NFL was like you're an
undefeated put it that lat at the end of
the regular season you lose to the
Dolphins yeah sorry like nah that's
that's what happens I said [ __ ] or
something on in Utah yes like now that's
it for this guy and then I did the the
Seattle competition yeah International
and then I started doing the Seattle on
the ground that's where I met you that's
interesting yeah because I remember
watching you and just being like
enamored but he's the thing with that is
that there's I always say that like
baseball it's like a five-tool player
you know yeah they want you to hit field
run you need to do all that whereas like
in comedy let's say you were only two
years in and and one if you were still
already like using all your other tools
yeah you're likeable you knew who you
were your voice was great you commanded
an audience but I wasn't remember the
jokes were good too and so I guess he's
banging on all cylinders like no I was
just older at the time you know I just
because it was like I tried when I was
22
probably
but how the age you were yeah I mean and
I just was like I you know I wish I was
doing what you were doing at 22 when I
was 22 I was 30 at that time interesting
yeah yeah so I was like you know I
regret not starting earlier no I regret
not continuing okay so I tell people all
the time that people don't people don't
fail in this business they quit that's
true
you know and so for me is like I got
quit for a little while I wish more
people would quit can we say that I mean
I some of the most comedians I've ever
seen in my life
I've seen in the last two years yeah and
in a better join and hanging in there
just I'm just like listen you're a
horrible comedian and this is male and
female I'm seeing a ton of shitty
females you're not excluded from this
this isn't just man-on-man crime now
there's some [ __ ] female comedians
they need to quit and there's some
[ __ ] male comedians that need to quit
but yes true names I'm not afraid what
could happen he really just said okay no
not bad I just don't care anymore no I'm
glad you said that
yeah cuz I this is one of the one things
I wanted to talk to you about yeah I've
known you a long time yep like we've
been friends but not necessarily close
but we've been in each other's circle
for yeah you know and I've noticed from
watching your Instagram mhm
you're different thank you you're way
more biting right now yeah I noticed you
have it's almost as if one day you went
you know what [ __ ] exactly and you and
you have a certain edge what happened
thank you for noticing that and or not
thank you for noticing I appreciate that
you noticed that because it shows that
you're listening yeah I am
yeah or that you care yeah I think that
I've just spent my life so much trying
to fit in in Seattle and being this alt
leftist and being this guy that's like
yeah man I agree with all these people
because that gives me a camp yeah and
then I started thinking for myself and
and then pursuing like real
intellectuals and not just pretend
intellectuals who bought an old hat from
the thrift store and think like oh I
hate it right you want an old typewriter
ya know I roll my own cigarette so I
must know more than you
no [ __ ] you didn't do any of the reading
you didn't forming your own thoughts you
just repeat [ __ ] you've those aren't
even your own ideas you just
regurgitating none since it's very
derivative so I started I basically just
started pursuing my own truth and and
when I did that I realized or liked it
and it took years and it took all these
different but there was just a day where
I was like I'm I've spent a lot of my
life pretending I believed something
that I didn't you know and so so when I
was very young I was like very all about
the church and why because I needed a
community when did that come from
my parents were agnostic and in the kids
at school that were nicest to me were
Church kids and so just trying to fit in
then I'd ask myself do you really
believe this or do you just like the
nice kids that are in church do you just
like the religious people because
they're nice to you so it's not that I
believed all that [ __ ] I just wanted
a group and then I had another second
coming of that in my life where I go do
I really believe in this transgendered
stuff do I really believe guns are bad
do I really believe I should apologize
for being a white guy I need to ask
myself those questions or am I just
calling myself a white devil and
pretending I love trans people even
though I've never met one and I you know
I'm saying like I needed to ask myself
those questions do I really believe this
and and and am i lying to myself and
everyone else just to fit in and make my
life more comfortable so interesting
because I feel like I had Tony
Hinchcliffe on their podcast do it Tony
was he had some very similar feeling
about like you know being a straight
white males like you know it's like oh
I'm one of the good ones sure way to
think yeah but it's like he's like he's
like I didn't do anything bad so why am
i but I also feel like you know also
didn't do anything to help me so of
course you know what I mean well that's
the problem is that nobody wants to rely
everybody plays like identity politics
we're all horrible and selfish and
narcissistic and evil it's like I'm not
a victim because I'm a straight white
male and you aren't for whatever your
[ __ ] camp is wholly agree with you so
what would I
I used have jokes the kind of one of the
jokes I used to tell and it's a great
joke I would say the one thing we need
to all be honest and realize is there
are there are bad black people and there
are
black people and there are bad Mexican
people and there are good Mexican people
and there are bad white people and there
are tolerable white people got a good
laugh but then on my mind I was like
that's kind of a dirty thing I just did
right there you know like is it funny
absolutely I said what visit my personal
truth okay now now when you do a joke
like that in the past yes was there a
part of you that was thinking oh man I
wonder how this is gonna be perceived no
no like if you weren't everyone knew is
funny I know but I felt like I feel like
though that before there was some of you
that was there was a part of you that
was like well you know I don't wanna I
don't wanna
Braque too many boats as opposed to
where you are now necessarily but there
was a lot of them right where I'd be
like I'll be the kitty cat guy right you
know there's enough people angry and
doing politics I'll be the guy that
talks about uh kids you know or be like
whatever like and I still try to do that
now except now I just I just want to be
truthful right I need the people to go
hey you know what I like that he's he
likes everyone and I think that's a
dying idea that I'm happy and that I
love everyone yeah but also I will I
have zero tolerance at this age for
anybody's victim nonsense no I need
triggers me I I could you know you know
how I could tell because I started to
you know when I really started to notice
it it's just like I'd see randomly at
the club and I would like to say
something to you like hey what's up man
or like be like or even I mean I could
be making some joke about something and
you would just have this like real like
heated strong reaction you'd be like you
know I'd be like oh just going through
something yeah is going through
something right now and I think that
it's like okay so like you are the
prototypes typical you know straight
white male yeah tall thank you aesthetic
you're attractive so like what I could
get away with on stage yeah you not
don't can't necessarily get it well
that's that's the thought process but it
doesn't necessarily mean it's true you
know cuz look at Tosh I mean Tosh like
you know Anthony Jeselnik you know I
mean yeah you know he just he picked his
lane and he sticks with it and he has
his audience and I felt I feel like
you're finally at this point in your
life going like oh I'm gonna find my
audience and I'm gonna be this way
absolutely and I think people I think
people you find who
is fine like you figure out who you are
like and and I think the crowds aren't
good at figuring out what's funny
I think crowds are horrible at figuring
out what's funny how many times have you
seen a hack on the road like kill ya
please crowd the road more like anyway
well I guess my point is how many sounds
a myth we've seen Jackie people ride
into action right we've seen bad comics
hack comics and we've seen great comics
all kill which means the crowd doesn't
know what is funny we know what's funny
but they don't really know what's funny
but the crowd does know what's honest
and I feel like that's the best one
thing I will give a crowds credit for is
I feel like they can sniff out truth
even when I'm phoning it in and I'm just
going through some jokes but transparent
on stage right but they can wit like so
even if I say something like I have a
line in my act where I'm like I say all
of our American problems are so trivial
like and that's what's really changed
perspective I went to over 50 countries
and I started looking at the way other
cultures live and and the way other
people are actually oppressed yeah not
just not pointing to billionaires and go
well I don't have that so I'm impressed
like go [ __ ] yourself so I started
realizing like yeah some people just
don't have water oh my god and then my
own friends are like well I ordered a
venti and she brought me a grande in
Italy and I'm just going that's not what
is what is wrong with you the fact that
you can afford $3500 for rent shows that
you're in the 1% of earth and I started
like working this out of my brain going
what are people complaining about and I
have a line in my act where I go
people's problems here like well I was
misgendered at a farmers market you like
shut up that's not a thing you made up a
thing
and when I say that in Iowa or Virginia
or Florida or Portland OR Seattle they
all laugh and they all because they're
gone he's being honest with his truth I
mean whether we're transit whether we've
been misgendered or we have very strong
opinions but I at least he's being
honest they can at least respect that
I'm saying something I really believe
you know it's funny that you talk about
this right now because I'm right that's
fine I'm actually literally talking
about this in my act right now about
what you're I'm saying I'm applying what
you're saying yeah in my act right now
because I to of I've been started
talking about the transgender issue as a
my point about it is is like I don't
care sure you know like what
realizing his people have causes too you
know and and they and they had these
causes and they try to jam them down
your throat and I'm not a monster
because I don't give a [ __ ] about it on
the same level that you do sure I think
most of us kind of live like I don't
think we care who's gay
Chuck we don't care if you want to be
transgender be transgender long do what
you want as long as it's not hurting
anybody
ya know I think that the issue with like
the thing with gay they've proven it
it's like a thing you know I think
there's our science behind it now and we
love that people love science yeah you
could prove some sort of data this is
what you know some people there is a gay
gene or whatever it is we've look at but
the transgender thing is like we're not
there yet with the science yeah and
actually this is the funny thing about
it is like there was this woman that
worked at Harvard I saw on Bill Maher
show and she got pushed out of Harvard
because she had this
she's has these studies about how young
kids who feel that way yeah oftentimes
go on and get over it and live a happy
healthy life oh nice yeah so but anyway
but of course the liberal side they go
hey get her at it get her out of here
this isn't true these people you know
and I go so I'm iffy on that when it
comes to like as long as you don't hurt
anybody
but I think that if we live in this
society would be to say that kids can't
vote fight in the army slow drive drink
same oak [ __ ] whoever they want to no
matter what age if we're telling them
that you can't do that why are we saying
to them now we trust their judgment 100%
so now we trust your judgment so I just
I I'm iffy on that this is a very
nuanced let's not take kids serious ever
you're right that's why I feel like if I
have a son he comes into my room and
goes dad I think I'm a Democrat I'll go
okay man just go watch a cartoon like I
don't have to take that serious yeah
yeah yeah and if he comes in he goes I
think that I'm more of a girl than a boy
I go okay yeah go in the other room I'm
never gonna take anything he says that
serious because he's still working
everything out on his own he's a little
boy but I just wouldn't start taking to
a doctor and go hey let's take his
wiener off he thinks he's a girl like I
wouldn't do any of those things I would
just dismiss it because I love him and
I'm just gonna continue to raise in ways
he's got to work all that out on his own
yeah
it's not gonna happen till he's a fully
functional adult but see this funny
thing about it right now is I think the
fight is that we feel that way about
kids for everything else
yes except yeah but most times gender
just these these leftist and that's the
thing they know I would have liked
jumped in that camp and be like it's
it's please these people matter and all
the stuff but it wasn't about you saying
that would've been used I would have
been 10 years would say no but there's
this community in there but they're
being hurt and everyone is ignoring it
and brushing it off and they say they
don't care how insensitive and but but
my but me saying that was just me going
look how open I am right look how sweet
is that Jeff a nice guy that there's
some that's no fault with the
transgender people are against and it's
naivety and it's this self-righteous
chip on your shoulder and that's my I my
own problem with transmitted transgender
community isn't the community yeah
people like my sisters people speaking
for the community like and and and
they're posted all these things on
Instagram and then I say okay name five
of your transgendered friends and they
don't know any yeah don't even know it
because it's not about the transgender
people how many how many of comics have
you seen palying around with a
transgendered person with a comedy club
I know I've never seen it I've never
seen it either yeah in those transgender
comedians there's actually rise
Silverman which I know I'm gonna get
really hammered on on the pronouns that
I'm using he might be a crossdresser he
might be translated or what I don't know
I know they I knew Raisa Merman when she
was a man and now is either a
cross-dressing man or a FEMA I don't
know and then there's another one that's
an Asian very funny I saw a roast battle
buddies thing I don't see them pal
around with anyone
yeah they don't even have comedian
friends iciness that aren't like I'm
saying so like even the most woke
feminist trends pro-trans comics don't
hang out with them or they don't have
any you know missing and by the way I
don't want to misspeak I don't I'm not
saying that I don't care what I'm saying
is like I just don't care to the level
of the extremes sure so the one thing I
do the one thing that makes me care
the transgender community is this idea
about kids that's all only at that point
I do feel it's like that's that makes me
gives me pause but I support like hey
once you become an adult you get to a
certain point it's like you know yeah
you know whatever do do do what you want
to do and my I say to everyone else like
hey keep me out of it yeah you know it's
like I'm just saying like I don't it's
like when you find out somebody's gay
you know who cares
exactly now who cares you know but
that's why most of time I don't talk
about it because it's like I don't think
they give a [ __ ] what my opinion is
either yeah why do I have to have a take
and then what right you know what have
what it becomes is like it's like when
you're when you're a minority okay for
me it becomes like when you're when
you're a minority and then whatever your
job is you become the minority that yeah
where'd you go to school I was just
going that way I'm from la loca you know
so I was I was born or raised in LA but
I went to all-boys Catholic school and
you were the minority in LA you know as
a brown person yeah yeah it depends on
where you it depends on where you go if
you have some like at your school you in
depends on the circle was the circle was
your mostly white
I mean yeah there was a lot of like you
know when I when I first went to when I
first was coming up I went to like
Brentwood okay I would just school in
Brentwood and I was just like all white
you know yeah
then I went to like my mom Seattle I was
the minority it was mostly Asian then
that was Asia but we didn't call ups
those minorities yeah yeah well I mean
but you could be a minority in a
particular setting yeah but like
societally you know that desk where it
changes you know what I mean I mean
there is such a thing as like you know
privileges is real like white privilege
is real male privilege is real but I
think female privilege is real too yes
because she never talked we never talked
about statistically white privilege
isn't even as big as asian privilege but
instead of calling an asian privilege we
say aren't they the hardest workers we
go to some prejudice we go to some
strange stereotype of like oh it's
because their parents are really are
hard on the tiger mom's make them want
to be doctors and Pete you know and
you're like what let's talk about like I
mean how much money goes into like
making sure that they get into
university and these kind of things and
we
there's like that stereotype has given
them a privilege in Western culture but
nobody wants to say Asian privilege it's
just easier to say I've been wronged and
white people are yes so you're like yeah
you do feel like the champion for white
people now not at all but all of the
things people feel towards white people
aren't inaccurate I'm let me be clear
evil lives in me that's my culture are
you related to it yes I am but I am a
product of racists who made me so that
I'm not not championing for white people
look in fact I'm almost saying we're all
bad yeah and I'm not gonna not disagree
with a guy cuz he's black that's the
stupidest thing I've ever heard and
there is that kind of happening in in
like being white is not a problem
anymore and it's not like it's it's real
pretty fun I'm sure we'll know but what
I'm saying is but what I'm saying is
that like we're not being wronged or
anything it's more like being invisible
nowadays so it's it's it feels more like
being invisible not not being or you
want to be invisible no we don't we want
to be heard when you want to feel like a
person but I'm saying that one thing
like what I'm saying is like so when the
stuff starts when the [ __ ] starts yeah
it's like when the me - movement starts
who it was like just being a man in
general yep it feels like that became
like a thing yeah you know you're like
it's like I get so tired of like you
know you know you're in the Comedy Store
lineup and then like some woman will
tweet at the lineup being like yeah I
hear you Laurie Kilmartin and I've
blocked you I don't care that there's
not women on the line yeah III might
think it's because for me I just go hey
take another look it's still mostly
white so yeah so don't forget about
don't forget what it took for me to get
here Eric I've said this on my pockets
but I don't want to I want to do go back
to court in comedy thing yeah but I I've
said this on my podcast if women are
getting any sort of if they're getting
in people's ear about how there's not
enough women on these comedy lineups
then black people need to be a lot
louder about how they've been [ __ ] in
business there's straight-up just black
comedy clubs because they haven't given
spots and and this so god this is hard
to articulate
there are a infinite amount of men who
think they're funny at our school we had
35 guys all championing for class clown
well I'm the funniest I'm the funnest
and we had like one funny girl yeah and
it wasn't because girls aren't funny
it's because they don't try to be they
don't value those sort of things if in
fact the women in my school at least
where I grew up is they were trying to
be smart and they were trying to be like
soccer players and they were trying to
be pretty and they were trying so how
many men did we have on our school
trying to be a dream to deal with that
rejection yeah and so like it's hard if
women just weren't trying to be funny
and that's exactly why comics there's so
many more male comics there's more men
trying to be comedians so if there's
less women and there's more men that
line ups are going to be dominantly men
however where this is it relevant is
that you know me black communities there
are a ton yeah that numbers are pretty
equal when you look at that like half of
all if you look into all the black
comedy clubs you look at all the open
mics you look at all the different
things there's a ton of talented and
untalented black comedians who aren't
getting the spots whereas women are a
very small part of our of our comedy
thing and tell more start turning up and
trying to be comics you were your the
minority in our group and then they want
that to be equally like dude there's not
enough guy talking with Andrew Santino
was on we said the same thing it was
like the ones that are doing it yeah are
doing it yes the ones that are supposed
to be on the line up there on the line
yes and it's just that they just not
can't be on it every single day so what
that's it that's the whole argument and
maybe there's some comics aren't are
they're playing dumb to how smart they
are it's there's a difference between
equality of outcome and equality of
opportunity so for example the Los
Angeles Lakers like Jeannie bus has
given auditions are tryouts I guess it's
called in sports to female athletes WNBA
players to college female basketball
stars but guess what happens they're not
as good as the men who play yes
so that opportunity was there she gave
them a shot and they just aren't as
strong or as big or as able as the men
who are the best at that sport so the
outcome is the same and the opportunity
was equal so in comedy they're just
gonna give equal opportunity
to the girls but also make sure the
outcome is equal you know you can't
that's why a girls bomb and every night
at comedy magic club is because they
have no girls but they need girls and
the only girl that turns up sucks I just
saying I'm not afraid to say it
no I yeah it's it's uh it'd be like
going to an a be like going to a
hospital in scoffing that all all the
nurses are female and it's like be like
this is [ __ ] this this is a sexist
hospital they've only hired 90% female
nurses no nursing services are full of
women who want to be nurses yeah
men don't tend to want to be that job
right right right right right ones that
want to they're there yeah is there I
might one of my best friends as a male
who likes it and he loves it but he's
probably around a lot of girls yes yes
his wife is a nurse who he makes do we
get mad that like do we call it a female
patriarchy like that all the babysitters
and nannies are female like no we go no
women are maternal they're better at
this love that joke by the way thank you
very much that was you go check out his
Instagram but that's the one I thought
that's the one I really knew yeah I was
already knowing something was going on
with you when I saw that I was like oh
he's full-on yeah you feel off finding
like you know you're a real true comedic
voice your personal trachea oh I think
like by squashing these things or even
having these kind of conversations and
then making that into something funny
that people like to hear is a way of
making equality by saying hey guess what
your life is pretty good and and we're
all the same and guess what I I am just
as bad as a feminist or a black guy or a
Mexican guy and I'm saying so by that's
my way of saying now the world's we're
good we're doing alright for the most
part we care I told you the fact that
you would say hey as long as you're not
hurting anyone
that's a really powerful statement like
some people that are bad in their heart
and not woke yet what would be like no
[ __ ] I hope we do hurt Muslims and I
think we should hurt gaping take the
civil rights movement they wanted them
to be hurt I know they would use
violence to make their message and
that's that's evil oh yes I told you
don't know what you're saying to do it I
just think it just comes with age and
growth and it's just like I I enjoy
having like intellectual Congress
stations even on stage sure I just you
know so the our job is to like let me
express in my premise and in my setup
that you know where I'm coming from so
you're not just labeled because what
happens in the comedy is people go if
you have a female in your joke you're
now a misogynist you know I mean if
you're white and you have you just
talked about a couple of black people
all this guy's racist saying black
jersey saying black people's like oh my
god I have a drink where I say fat black
lady and then the punchlines like a
positive part and I can't tell you how
fast I watch people go from triggered
and then because the punch because the
punch line is positive to go okay I look
I personally love that look listen I say
fat [ __ ] on stage amazing yeah I like
saying like Isaac I'll say big [ __ ]
yeah it's just because I like how it
rolls off the tongue you know you're
that big [ __ ] you know I love it you
know but I'm just saying like I have a I
personally like having a take and what
I'm realizing is it's important to
really articulate what you're trying to
say because the message gets lost into
delivery
absolutely and also I've worked with MS
Pat on New Year's who I adore I love
miss been watching her set was kind of
proof to this you know it's not against
the law to be racist right you know it's
not against the law to be an [ __ ] so
guess what the we are among racists and
we are among [ __ ] and guess what
they're allowed to do that
is it wrong sure is it annoying but
guess what they're allowed to do that
and and when you also adopt that in your
mind yo you know I have access to all
the words and I could say all the words
and once you know that kind of freedom
you could say big [ __ ] and if it's
funny enough people go I love that guy
and that was great it's just don't
hesitate just cuz you think it's not
against the law but that's a comedian
thing like a comedian thing is like I
always show people like if they don't
ever I say don't have your demeanor show
that you're apologizing for what you're
saying because the moment you feel like
that the crowd is gonna go like this
yeah you're not supposed to say that
right you know so you have to oh oh yeah
whatever you say I love pets so the only
time I've slipped up on this was in
Tacoma Washington and I have
in that specific city there um all the
door guys they're like these big black
guys and they're like my friends and I
love him to death and they were like
dude you cut it close to that because I
slipped
I love referring to people as chimps
because I think that we kind of are that
way well but we also think we're smart
and we're not most of us are pretty
stupid like when I ask people who they
voted for they'll say the president and
I say yeah but who are the other people
you voted for what about like in like a
local like they don't know they think
they're informed voters but they don't
even they only know like the three main
people and they go Hillary you know and
so I like ask it like I kind of try to
like needle on them and and then I just
yeah I try to remind everyone that we're
pretty stupid and ignorant and bias and
and we should just get along and love
each other because you're not smarter
than anybody you think you are but
you're as smart as we think we are but
the problem is I started ranting about
Richard Sherman and I go this [ __ ]
chimp oh yeah and then it was like oh no
let's write write write [ __ ] people have
their own Association yes people the
crab like did he just call them I mean
my mind doesn't know no and because I
didn't just plow through and ignore what
I said I addressed this no no I usually
call people chimps and they're like no
you called Richard no no wasn't and so
did you not call did you not make a
chimp reference before that no I had I
guess I kind of just gotten into it you
did a call back from a previous set what
like Galica almost like oh they all know
how I speak right right they didn't know
how I spoke and slowly and then the door
guys but they know me so they're like oh
man you he's like I can't believe you
want everyone back because I think I did
that like the first six minutes yeah cuz
Richard Sherman like broke my heart he's
a player of the plate the CIA he's one
of my favorite players like I was
obsessed him I defended him tooth and
nail every time he did something stupid
in the media and and then he chose to go
play for our rival team yeah and and I
hated that move because um he was like
well Seahawks didn't want me so I can go
to whatever team I want yeah but you
chose to go to the team we hate on
purpose that's like me breaking up with
my girlfriend and then her having sex
with my best friend and being like well
you didn't want me yeah but you
intentionally went and [ __ ] my best
friend whatever they do and that's what
sure yeah
and that's what Sherman did to the
Seahawks and so I was just ranting about
that you know he thinks he's so smart
and then I said and I think oh god and
now I'm gonna have to I'm getting
cancelled now but it went over what
finals like thank God nobody recorded
this I know just things out of context
here so but you just feel like we're
talking about similar things man because
I talked about this voting thing all the
time man where cuz I'm like you know
especially in LA I always say like like
especially white women to just run amuck
during the voting time cuz it's just all
in your business but I'm like they
always ask if you vote and that's not
the right question the right question is
are you informed about who you're voting
for sure and I always bring up the point
I always bring up the point like when
you get to ballot in the mail yeah you
know because people say vote right now
and they always think what Trump yes I
said we're gonna vote they just think
it's just Trump dude we got a vote for
the county controller sure do you even
know who the [ __ ] that is right most
people can't even name their own like
congressman yeah the Congress man you to
vote for the sheriff we have to vote for
the judges nobody knows anything about
these things that's what the voting
system is it's a smartest thing Daniel
Tosh
well not the smartest I think is genius
he gets mad when I call him a genius and
brilliant he's always like so like
dismissive of that but he is he said on
stage one night and maybe it's just a
throwaway thought but it was so smart
because you know we should do is have
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump live on
television with no edits they both have
to take the SATs and we filmed them
taking the SATs and then we post their
results and then we'll say look these
are the people and it's so true I want
to do that with all my friends like sit
down I've spent so much time to call
myself dumb and then I did all the
reading and I did forget to SAT yeah
just the driving test yeah have you
taken that [ __ ] like I know I wouldn't
bet when I just had to get my license
again like it was a couple years back
yeah man I was this close to failing
like I had to answer the question
cuz when you fail yeah they write on the
counter they go okay you failed but
there's you can make up with these five
questions oh yeah and also they don't
they let you take it three times you're
back and then you got this it was
actually D you got
any like wait a minute but some of them
are like it's not some of them are
common sense I know well I have a racial
conspiracy about the dam because I
thought it was like common sense that
you got all your common sense but no one
will be like if there's a truck on the
road and that like there's certain
things you go oh that can't be right
and it's like yes yeah I can't do this
or whatever
I think the DMV has a racial bias I
really Brown so they've because we're in
the word game we write every day we know
how to manipulate words and put the
right part at the end Brian we know you
know let's lead them down this path and
they give them a misdirection so they're
okay they do that in the in the
questions because it makes English more
complicated but if you know you've got
people that have English as a second
language or people who know all the
Stratham do you speak English
and they'll say yes and so they give me
anglish version not the Spanish version
they know that there's a Spanish version
yeah they'll only let them have that if
they have zero semblance of thing and so
there's all these word games in it and I
remember being like wow this isn't my
battle but [ __ ] this place because I
know English well sounds like I'm
hanging them out but I'm even still
confused you guys like white they were
like it was weird why is this worded
this way it's I guess I'm weird
Limerick I've got to work they give you
the the freaking multiple choice options
yes even that's worded in a way that I
go this could be anything also think
about this they give you a driver's
license at 16 and then they just go you
know how good this is for forever yeah
you're never gonna test again
I know do you know I'm saying like so
like my great-grandma I don't know if
now in California might be different but
at least in Washington she got her
driver's license and then she would tell
she turned 90 that was just I mean she'd
have to renew it but she didn't have to
drive anywhere should have to put a
person in the passenger seat no yeah
she'd do anything they just go that'll
be good forever you probably not go
through anything in life that will
affect your driving skills every job my
mom has dementia right now she's like
adamant about driving you like no but I
what I want to do is oh I just wanna I
want to take her ass down to the DMV and
be like okay no that's a good idea
you know but then I just don't subscribe
to yourself yeah should be soaked
because I've seen or dude I understand
though that like oh I failed
no no then it's not worth yeah it's not
you're right it's not worth it but I
just have it to show her like you might
be you drew a chipmunk here grand man
you know it's like it's I don't know I
mean I I hate that we still live in a
world where we have to continuously be
aware of race and gender right and it's
so freaking annoying especially you as a
comic it becomes annoying cuz sometimes
you just want to go on stage and you
want to go I want to talk about this and
I want the audience to fill in the
blanks with common sense sure but it
just honestly doesn't work like that and
then you find that it doesn't even work
like that even when you're having
conversations with people I was I was
auditioning for this show dr. ken
actually owned a project with envision
back in the day dr. kay it was his
British sitcom first came on I went out
for like one of these parts and I'm
testing for it okay I'm in the lobby and
then one of the guys is testing he's
like he's gay super gay so we just
having a conversation you know and I'm
just we started the gay parade was
coming up and I go I was like yeah I
said listen I can't stand that gay
parade you know I'm like it just [ __ ]
up traffic yeah you know he's like this
oh it's about the traffic you know I
think yeah [ __ ] is that a [ __ ]
traffic yet the majority yeah it's all
about the traffic you know because I
have to go to the comedy store and you
have to pass all that you can't get to
the comedy show you're affecting my
career affecting like you know but he
just would not let it go then she's this
[ __ ] he just would not let it go that it
was about that you know I mean well cuz
yeah it's something that he thinks is
really special but here's the things
like all the things we think are very
special don't affect traffic at least
all the church people are in a church
yes man they're not in the street listen
if they was like yeah if there was a
Catholic you know I don't like marathons
either by over a year there's a Mormon
parade that shuts down 17 streets
I'd also vent to you about that thank
you I would be like you don't have more
memory that says [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
up my career
go yeah [ __ ] these Mormons were they
really because he would feel if I father
said to me let's talk about the LA
Marathon because I can't stand that [ __ ]
either
he got a marathon you got a driver's
cafe and I can't he would do the same
thing I was so annoyed by there was one
thing in his little craw yeah and I just
go damn ice this sucks
yeah so it's like you know you find it
but then you find yourself wanting to be
around I have a lot of comedian friends
and I think I have a lot of comedian
friends because I know I could say some
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
Tim Dylan you know we could say certain
what we like about each other is that
like it's like the old days you can
speak freely yeah and like even if I say
like a horrific joke about like abortion
or something and you're with you some of
your other non comedian friends they'll
be like huh and yeah you'd go at naam
he's just making a joke was a good joke
nobody tries that's what I would be
talking about what he's doing so you
really want to go with that one you know
I mean but it's like you just we just
don't have that we don't have enough of
that in society I thought that social
media was gonna be that outlet you know
well yeah it's just it's now that's
getting please it's really not yeah it's
like it really said it I think maybe
it's Joe Rogan or remember who said it I
don't often quote Joe Rogan but peep
this somebody says like there's so many
people working you know like there's
some people like in cubicle jobs and
factory jobs and things and HR is such a
big deal to try to keep like a safe work
environment that now we've made society
like an HR thing like oh I can't say
that in society because he's like no you
can yeah you could say whatever you'd
like in society you have freedom of
words the of them free that's a tool you
can use your words
so like like you probably should never
say the n-word but if you're trying to
upset a black guy and you want to get in
a fistfight that's the go-to word if
there's your goal yeah yeah yeah what a
great tool what are you trying to
achieve right yeah if your goal is to
hurt someone's feelings and you're
yelling at a lady the c-word is a very
effective tool yeah it is it's not
against the law to fire that out there
yeah that's if you want those social
consequences go ahead that's yeah but
now you have social consequences by
saying anything on Twitter and all this
kind of stuff but got more mad at
Roseanne Barr for making an
full racial tweet then they did Jesse
what is it juicy small Assam yay
you know that guy like they did a whole
thing nobody can't people did care but
people were like can he make a comeback
I don't can his career bounce back what
he did I'm actually so glad that that
happened yep that he ended up being a
liar yeah the reason is is because all
of my liberal Hollywood friends only I'm
looking on their Twitter and they were
like what happened to the size of Trump
who they don't know and it's like you
know what he did was he weaponized yeah
he weaponized this liberal [ __ ] sure
he weaponized it he's like oh I know
what to do because people will be
outraged yes and I'll get this victory
now Gladys victim credit and he
weaponized that it's so easy to do and
it's like it's like anything that pisses
me off is why people don't understand
why we have due process in the court
system absolutely we have do suppose
process we supposed to but the due
process is important it's like you know
let's say when the me to thing first
came out it was like it was hard man yes
it was like you know somebody can say
whatever they want and then it was all
this like believed the victim right no
you take the victim serious yes you
investigate and then you come up with
you know a conclusion or you come up
with like a plan of action but just to
be like oh whatever you say is true
because you said it go [ __ ] yourself
there's a female community I won't say
her name just cuz I bet she doesn't she
you know she's not here I don't know how
she feels
yeah but she was like someone tell you
something girl friend of mine text me
she was we're all going down to the me
too thing to tell our stories are you
gonna come and she listed all the people
that were coming and then she goes oh no
no no I know thank you
I'm not I don't have like a me to story
and the girl replied girl we all have a
me to story she wants her to go through
her head just think of a find a time
that you felt uncomfortable around a
dude and then just go share that and
like I just couldn't believe that that
was the way but the lines are so blurred
i mean i that i listen i when that was
going on I started I looked back and I
thought damn have I been
appropriate was did I make someone
uncomfortable and it's just like I've
been wildly inappropriate with females a
number of - I'll admit to my Metis
here's the difference is that the girl
hot no not that it's that the girl don't
bother [ __ ] back if the differ were
mutually interested but I was very
aggressive what and and I've since been
like very like oh my god I know that was
I was too drunk I was like I was way too
you know they were like they liked me
and they wanted to do that with me but I
was being yeah I get it the predator
lion and I blurred those lines a lot of
times and then me too movement I don't
know for better or worse like now I'm
just like you got to do everything now
you've gotta yeah we live like bumble
yep I don't olya but it did my
ex-girlfriend I must have me to her
weekly my girlfriend right now I feel
like how I got with her it was like I
was aggressive what's up I'm not
advocating for that either
I know but it's like you know you go but
I think you you have to use common sense
yeah it's like you know what when you
see it that's what they say about like
sexual harassment on the job tell that
to people when 90% of our society is
some level on the spectrum I know but
it's like this it's like what's
pornography right yeah like you can't
necessarily because because if I show
you anything you could be like oh this
is pornography you know but it could be
like you know your your your baby
cousins your your sister or somebody
said you here's my twins and then
they're naked in a thing it's an just
showing that to someone else that might
be like this is pornographic but the
real answer to pornography is the same
thing you know it when you see it we
know it when we see it yeah some some
people are just socially inept and they
still want to have sex and they still
want to have partnership and so then
they just they don't know what they're
doing I think they're just I think
people are playing a part right now I
think you know did you ever do you watch
Joe Rogan's podcast at all and sometimes
I just catch some clips I catch some
clips you know but there was one with a
guy that Adam ruins everything guy
I was talking with Joe Rogan about the
transgender issue you know and the way
he was talking about it and what I love
about Joe Rogan he's so even keel
you don't mean like he doesn't get super
excited about things because at this
point now he's having a conversation
with somebody's getting their sign so he
has to be like let me live you know and
the way Joe Huckabee he said but what
about you know this this and this and
this guy his whole demeanor too I felt
was oh I'm I'm going to make sure that
the Liberals that support me know that
I'm on their side sure and I go I think
that's so insulting to people and I
think this is what happens in these
situations is what people do is they go
I don't necessarily want to state my
true opinion or or go through the
process of finding it with someone
because maybe I might say something or
be perceived in the wrong way and I
always want to be perceived that she's
the problem
it's right and that's what we talked
about earlier that yeah I came to the
conclusion of like what is my personal
truth yeah and I blame people for crying
on both sides I'm tired of hearing this
side crying I'm tired of these people
going there taking my guts Oh everyone
stop crying like it's so annoying and
both sides and even the mushy middle are
guilty of it the mushy middle you call
it yeah like I'm like I'm somewhere in
there no mushy middle you're in the
mushy indifferent you just try to live
your life yeah I guess I guess I really
am trying to just live my life so it's
like that guy right now I talk about on
stage is like you know it's like I don't
care about the gay issue anymore so like
if you're gay be gay yeah and then and
then the people that hate gays um I go
[ __ ] off man I don't don't bring that to
me sure that's your thing you're not
because most of us don't care you'd like
this oh this is a new thing I've never
done this on stage Nikki Glaser was like
you have to do all right what is it so
like obviously racism is the worst
you know like that's the top of like is
it well but I mean like for you know for
what people I know go through and like I
guess that I've witnessed like my
friends have been victims of racism that
that they have a victim hood higher than
me but right under that is being a white
guy being lumped into someone else's
racism you only get the Comedy Store and
Tommy's like come here man you believe
these and you're like oh no
he saw my white face and was like he's
like me and like Nene and because you
don't want to tell the guy that's in
charge of your fate like hey dude
that is racist like I get lumped it
after all these comedy shows the old man
will come and come here man you like you
like jokes but black doesn't know I know
it's like turned down some sweetheart
who just wanted to share a street jug
with me that he only thing I would add
to that is just your pecking order as I
think you I think that you should have
others in the pecking order but yeah I
think like I think it's like I think
racism and sexual assault yeah or like
very there's I think they're equal
they're right in there up there you know
what I mean and then then you had that
because I actually know exactly you
saying I was in Syria about ten years
ago I was in Syria nice doing shows
first time they had Americans doing
shows and I was at a I was at this
little gathering yeah afterwards and the
anti-semitism oh yeah was so casual that
I was like oh [ __ ] like and then what am
I supposed to say shut up you know but
it was so casual to be like you know if
it was like you know oh the weather
today and somebody was like well you
know the Jews yeah it was like you know
the Jew it was like I was like oh [ __ ]
like this is real so I know what you're
saying like when what people act like
offense when somebody thinks it's okay
to say some [ __ ] about like because what
you're saying is like if some white
people got around you and they were and
they thought it was okay to be racist
around you yeah that's insulting it is
when it's funny is I think wouldn't this
might be what maybe Tony Hinchcliffe had
in common with me is that I'm not
championing for white people ever but I
do want to make it known that racism is
not exclusive to white people like
travel the world you chimps like see how
people talk like in white black Asian
don't forget the engines think about
like okay so this is a true story I was
in a van in Kyoto Japan and it's just
mostly producers and stuff for the TV
show all white mostly and then in the
back is like a 15 passenger van and in
the very back is our translator so like
when we would go to a place we would
talk through her because it
more effective to try to get shots setup
will go to society we didn't bring our
translator but like we were trying to
get work done and shoot we're in Kiel to
Japan and I'm on my one of my little
stupid Jeff dies like yeah I talk talk
talk a lot yeah so I'm saying uh you
know braces do not exclusive to white
people without even addressing her no
one asked her to do this the art
translator pops up me she goes that's
true we hate the Japanese yeah oh no no
she was Japanese cuz he's killed you
because that's true we hate the Koreans
yeah she just offered up like here's my
racist thing yeah you're right I'm a
racist and he's right I'm not I'm not
white
it was so why black people can be very
racist it's my Amaro races to other
black people lighter skin to them hey
welcome to my world but so like like
races there is the tons of racism and it
should all be eradicated but the edges
of the plates the point you're making
earlier as I totally agree with about
people need to travel the world like any
time I had talked about this on my last
special cuz anytime I hear anyone say
the United States is the most racist
place in the world this one thing I know
about that person they've never traveled
any obvious they don't have a passport
because like in my example of it is in
European countries at soccer matches
mmm-hmm they throw bananas yeah at black
players not twenty years ago not thirty
years ago today I've they're throwing
bananas and I my point is this if one
banana hit LeBron James it's over this
this bit riot we would shut this [ __ ]
down I've been flipping cars white
people would be outraged in this country
if that happened i friend derec maybe
but not wrong so it's like don't come at
me with this [ __ ] light like we're
soda yes we got issues yes we got
problems and this is we have class
issues a lot of class issues going on in
our country but like let's not act like
there isn't some really awful [ __ ] going
on in the world that's why I was like I
wish that like I had some sort of
platform when Kanye West said honey West
goes George W Bush hates black people
and I was like George Bush hates poor
people
yeah and so do you got a lot of black
friends that are rich any his you know
you know what I file a below faz a
self-hating liberal because okay to be a
liberal and to have some wealth yeah you
know you're doing okay yeah I'm not
gonna lie I'm doing alright
life's we are now hypocrites okay cuz
it's hard to because I have so many of
these liberal friends now that I have
money and you know it's like the
Liberals will be like when you have
money it's hard for you to be talking
about you know what I don't like what's
going on at the border but you live in a
gated community okay so explain why
that's better cuz cuz I'm very proud
that I'm wealthy and I talk about it off
no no III know but why you I don't know
because I'm saying is because the
liberal values that are pushed out all
the time that we don't necessarily agree
with them you don't mean that's why we
live in a gated community or we live in
a place where you got to get buzzed in
it's like the the don't fat shame that's
why we got trainers and like not me but
you know what I mean I find a hip-hop
music to be hypocrites in class system
of like oh I'm from the get over the
trap but I got millions and I got gold
teeth and I got well I find that to be
hypocritical that's the same kind of
hypocrisy those what I'm saying to is
like you're not one of these people
anymore you're not one of the the
blue-collar people anymore you're
somebody for instance take Silver Lake
they live in like a freakin 1.5 million
dollar condo and then they stepping over
homeless people yeah and they act like
they're so you know but here's one of
them I have a friend I'm I'm gonna say
on anyway
either the actress mm-hmm this is what
happens a lot an actress if she was fact
mmm you know and she's out here you know
body positivity
too you know so you got fat girls out
there going like oh thank you for making
me feel but then that same fat actress
will go and lose all that way absolutely
get healthy sure so what about the army
a big [ __ ] at at home plate we were
like I thought this was okay right so
that's the hypocrisy up they don't
believe it exactly I don't believe it
it's whatever's good exactly all my
shapes are important no Dame
yeah and even you love those shoes
listen I'm in my freaking forties it's
so hard to lose weight for me right I
promise you if you lose weight you'll
lose fans do you know that look at Jonah
Hill no but yet no no because he looks
weird but also be much fun he's always
gonna be right here and my voice because
I've fluctuated in my weight now for you
but I will listen black by the way I
want to lose weight and that's why I'm
talking about it I'm talking about it in
a way that I know this ain't healthy
yeah so when I hear people talk about
you know body positivity and stuff I
just want to go it annoys the [ __ ] out
of me because I'm like no I don't want
to be like this so I have to take the
steps and the steps are heart so this is
what I can't stand
so because it's hard we go no let's just
make it okay it's lazy it's lazy as hell
take responsible take the responsible
arm saying is like that's what I'm
saying that's what happens when when you
give and you get some money by the way -
when you start getting money then you
start thinking about the taxes and
you're starting to go what's happening
with respective yeah you get perspective
been bitching about because they've been
rich for so long noticing potholes tent
of homeless people in front of my eyes
dude that's all the situation that wage
is getting ridiculous
you just made me think of a thought are
you saying the the hypocrisy of being a
liberal being a wealthy liberals hard
it's alright look all I'm trying to say
is I think wealthy liberals need to take
a step back and kind of shut the [ __ ] up
you know I I just really feel like you
know you're you're trying to speak for
people who you don't speak for you don't
speak don't stop trying to speak for
impoverished people in a way that like
you think you understand it's all I'm
saying you know yeah I was all about
that again in my last special I talked
about protesting at award shows to me
it's like it's so ridiculous straight-up
said you act like you're so woke but you
work for Apple Amazon and Disney who
have sweatshops he's like he's like
don't come up here and get your trophy
and use it as a platform for your
political stance [ __ ] you
nothing about this world get your little
trophy Thank You agent thank your God
and [ __ ] off ID and then you stop people
knowing who I thought Tom Hanks was like
yeah I was gonna say a thing about a
thing no I thought III was I was
surprised these home relic I was
surprised he still was allowed to be the
host because he's so but good for them
well I think it's capitalizing on it
they know that you know this second that
modeling was done it was already on
NBC's website well before people were
gonna search it that people don't watch
TV they're gonna first of all though
here's the problem with the award shows
to me is that you know you know who else
watches TV Trump supporters mmm you know
middle America sure they like movies -
yeah so yes so they want to alienate 60
70 million people with this with this
[ __ ] holier-than-thou I'm gonna speak
down to everybody attitude to teach
their liberal Hollywood elite not even
liberal just Hollywood elite going these
award shows and they run their [ __ ]
mouth yeah and then that's why the
ratings are down because middle America
is like yeah yeah come on I don't I
don't want to watch this and then there
and then some of us are like why are you
preaching to the choir
absolutely cuz only people watching
right now yeah why you guys easy why you
guys are sucking yourselves off it's
just it's easy because people want
what's easy similar to what your body
thing is well isn't it just easier to be
fat oh no we great food you don't have
to move around a lot bread for a month
and I'm like okay guess why we celebrate
people and maybe not maybe I shouldn't
use supermodels as an example because
they've done a lot of unhealthy things
to create that image but we celebrate
people that are fit because it's so hard
and and what I don't think people
realize how hard it is it's so hard I
don't think they realize like you know
what I loved about Kamal you don't want
to get you know what's the same say his
name you know to get in shape become a
comic you know he's on a
a political guy no no oh yeah yeah I
know he's on the HBO show yes he just
did a movie with a boat ista yeah I
thought it was photoshopped no nobody is
no no but you know what I love about he
let us off the hook because he put it
out there he was like this was a lot of
work yes he was like it was expensive
trainers yep and dieting for a year and
it was like all he was explaining how
difficult it was to get his body like
that absolutely so it is really hard so
that's why we admire it but what people
don't want what's hard but they know I
don't think the people out here really
they they don't want to talk about that
part of it it's like yes easy to like
have a bad diet trust me I know it's
easy to like not eat healthy it's easy
to like not take vitamins yep not brush
your teeth not floss they got the
deplorable vegans everyone likes to make
fun of do you know how hard it is to be
a vegan that is the most disciplined
group of people and I know it's easy to
hate because you because you think well
I enjoy bacon so much how could these
people hate a thing I love well I love
[ __ ] a lot but I'm not mad at gay guys
for not enjoying you know I'm saying so
what happened people are I don't think T
Rexes were out there like shaming
brontosauruses like look at those
[ __ ] eating trees they're eating them
yeah they weren't like it's funny to
each their own but I think that like
that's something that's lost is like
things that things can be admirable that
you're not trying to do because it's
difficult then that's and I think the
weight loss thing is one of the things
that's very difficult getting in shape
is difficult being at our most optimal
self is the difficult thing to achieve
but I just think that we need to stop
lying to society yeah to make look at
Liz oh I mean she's gonna die in ten
years if she keeps this up and then
she's just championing to overweight
girls to continue to to just be big and
do what you want and and eat bad and
sell it we should yeah that's a bit like
what does it cut like obesity obesity is
real yeah you know and they don't want
to see it and that people are there
their obesity deniers you know like
obesity is like liberals global warming
yep
you know 99 percent of scientists say
this is
real thing but these [ __ ] want to be
like no yeah feel good about yourself
what I love you fat and I love you
skinny but I guess what I'm not gonna
feel that bad for you when you have a
heart attack I know I have a good friend
who's like so political annoyingly
political and she just had some health
problems I've never seen her without a
cigarette in her mouth right so your
goal Moke cigarettes yourself smoke
cigarettes 24 hours a day and then you
want me to you want me to Facebook but
oh my god girl get well it's like you'd
like that can take responsibility that
kind of chick I don't want to hear her
talking about how we need health care
for everyone and she does she should go
[ __ ] herself okay like you here's the
thing if you smoke if you're a smoker
paper and all this stuff no no you
should have a really high deductible
yeah
no we don't get to pay for your choices
yeah that's another thing politically
that like is very complicated is like I
think you shouldn't even be allowed to
have Big Macs if you want the government
to pay for yourself the words should be
a syntax just like a cigarette
absolutely you know like I say if you
had a certain body percentage you should
you you have a high deductible like my
insurance shouldn't be the same as your
insurance absolutely you know everything
by the way going to the gym should be
free that should be part of your
insurance yeah yeah that's what I think
I think going to the gym should be free
I should be part of that cuz cuz taking
care of your health you don't go to the
doctor as much so you're not using that
insurance money as much because you're
more you're healthier so I just think
these are kind of things but that's what
I'm saying
it's the hypocrisy that we all live in
well I think it's so annoying I don't
have you ever listened to like Jordan
Peterson but he's a genius
and he always talks about like this
people think the secret to life is like
being happy all the time now the secret
to being the secret to having a
productive life is not only having
purpose but taking responsibility once
you have a purpose so you take rats
right and you give them cocaine and
they're very addicted but if you take a
bunch of rats and you put them in a maze
they don't care about the cocaine
anymore because they've found some sort
of purpose they're looking for a nice
and that's our lives why is the Midwest
taking opioids and do it because their
city is depressing and they don't have a
purpose and like what am I gonna work at
Walgreens for the next [ __ ] 30 years
no I'm gonna blow my brains out because
this is not a good way it's al they're
living in hell and so like you people
need to find a purpose and they need to
take responsibility instead
crying about how their rights are being
taken away and it's because they look a
certain way that earth has treated them
bad and it's pathetic
you heard it here you know I got what I
got we need to get to get into sports
some stuff man
I know sports I'll come back my podcast
yeah yeah yeah whoo flip-flop or have
them wanna gay because I feel like this
is a good stopping point I listen man
I'm I've known you for a long time you
know I'm older than you so it's easy for
me to say I'm proud of you because I am
you know I really like where you're
going in your head I saw that on
Instagram the other day and I saw that
the weight it's not just the material by
the way it's not just the material yeah
it's the way you were delivering the
material yeah it was a way it was like
there was a bite to it thank you
it was like you know it was lecture The
Improv just last night about what I
guess it was two nights ago I'm getting
to my material dude well actually but I
could feel something from them yeah and
so uh it says some people started
getting up right when they said my name
to go to the bathroom and I was like you
know what what is this
and then the crowds are going what's
happy guys and then I was like you don't
even want me to do well the second the
host said my name most of you thought I
haven't ever heard of him before he's
not famous you don't even care if I'm
good at stand-up I've done this every
night of my life for 14 years it's
something I care about it's something I
love and you mutants
you only care about going to work
tomorrow and name-dropping like
Sebastian Maniscalco willingly you don't
even give a [ __ ] why am i working on
trying to make a change and make you
feel happy and make you laugh when wall
I should be doing is getting a tick-tock
and [ __ ] dancing around for fora
that's all you care about look at our
comedy clubs are full of UFC fighters
and wrestlers and some [ __ ] with a
podcast who's never told a bit in their
life I just really feel it well that's
they they gave me an applause break
there you go
I called the mutants and I said that
your stupid name drop will you be honest
they could smell that and they're you
know what maybe he's right yeah maybe we
do just want the Instagram photo maybe
maybe we're just letting
rogon think for us when only thing we
love about joe rogan is that he thinks
for himself they they love joe rogan
thinks for himself and that beautiful
yeah but then they just take his
thoughts and regurgitate them yeah it's
well there it is there it is you know
the the brilliant Jeff died in trance
transforming and right before our eyes
you know what I mean I feel it you know
it's like so you're in your and so that
means you still have a ways to go
because right now as you're working
through it and trying to find out who
you are what kind of voice you I think I
think you're gonna get back to like
happy Jeff I'm very happy but he's you
don't to be but on stage that's peace
happy Jeff wants day when the storm
right now you're in the canoe my biggest
problem too is I get having an emotional
outburst because I'm a happy-go-lucky
guy too and so but sometimes on my
station I feel like oh I'm being too
yeah I'm being too like aggro whatever
it is like that so I'm trying to work on
that myself but it's like I said ongoing
process I've heard I remember who was
like maybe it's Brian Regan he said the
difference like the turning point in his
career was when he realized like I
should just be telling them jokes I'm
performing jokes and then also sometimes
Jerry Seinfeld said this once and and I
won't say it as beautifully as
articulate Jerry is but somewhere along
the idea is something like this is that
like we're not just like putting ideas
out there like hey here's an idea
we should be telling them the ideas yes
we've already came up with it and we're
telling them the idea instead of going
do you like this no no here it is and
there's a big difference between that
because they kind of going oh is he just
half baking this that's why they don't
like seeing a notebook on stage is
because they go but he didn't even
respect us enough to like prepare
something and by the way I love when I
Anthony Jeselnik Oh literally say that
yeah he says like cuz he says I'm
working on this he goes and why do I
have this cuz I don't respect you as
body yeah which is hilarious and it's
he's that's so true
honest thing I don't respect you as an
audience I'm a karmically is brilliant
and the second that he had that special
where the notebook was on the stool I
thought no no dude you might have
thought that was like a some like cool
thing like look this is like all just
coming off the top money it's sick
thoughtful ideas that are half-baked it
shows that you don't respect them you
just plain doesn't respect that crowd or
the people who downloaded it and I
watched every minute of it I loved
Jerrod and loved Spike Lee but you have
some class it's not different to be
lazier yeah well you know I'm a good
friend of Gerard's and like I always had
these heated discussions with him about
his artistic choices but like I want to
tell you there are all choices and I
love him and I like what and you know he
could say I tried something or I've seen
like Dave Chappelle bring those notebook
onstage and do it but it's because it's
the Comedy Store and there's like 50
people that it was with again again
weird choice you know very strange you
know it's strange choice it's just like
you know there was it be my choice now
your choice no but you know I think
that's the Louie CK like when I'm people
don't even want to hear his name anymore
brother he started this really weird
expectation of like Oh especially here
an hour a year where like when we and
I'll put you in this group like when we
at least we were in school we would
watch people put out an album and they
worked on that for like eight years
don't like it felt like it wasn't it
listened the word special needs to be
taken off of this is all content yeah
it's just content well I think that like
Tosh talked about that one time with me
in private is he was like dude I wish
that I didn't put out any of that stuff
but I had it all and then I just did
like almost a highlight reel of all
those things that came out and then that
would be the special everybody got this
special is amazing it's like yeah cuz it
took me 15 years to come up with all
that right right
idea here an idea there and a fun joke
here and a clean thing and then a dirty
thing and then it just people don't take
your whole library and strip it of all
the [ __ ] that worked that's the special
I know that's what would make it special
but it just uh but now we need to call
something like the greatest hits or
something I love you love you Adam right
but dude you have why I put one notes I
had this magical thing happen at the
Ontario improv
why have I put up this clip people are
doing whole specials of kawaii no I
don't like that's the whole thing like I
just need content and what's the
quickest way to generate that it's to
show how witty I am with an audience
member which is kind of cheating because
they already gonna like me anyways and
it seems brilliant off-the-cuff improv
nonsense
I personally hate when a crowd like
let's say I do a 45-minute set our set
yeah but there was some drunk chick that
I dealt with for three minutes
yeah I hate yeah somebody comes with me
afterwards and goes it was her oh no no
that and you know what my favorite part
of the whole thing was I was like so
this this material that I've been
working on it's slaving over this this
act did I put together yeah you're
telling me that you don't that's the
point
get a tick-tock nonsense make them mean
it's all over but in closing but I think
that it really is about understanding
the difference I think you're dealing
with this right now I think we're all
dealing with this but me and you
particularly you're like cuz I just
talked about this on a solo episode that
did that it's about balancing locus and
trying to make a point about something
and being entertaining sure it should be
funny also that's what Nanette missed
Nanette what what a beautiful idea what
a beautiful sentiment what a beautiful
meaning what a beautiful speech but it
wasn't funny yeah like what then why is
this stand up that's the thing they call
that a one-woman show or something yeah
cuz it would be like if Martin Luther
King like if you took the I dream I have
a dream speech and then you put it on
HBO and said comedy special exactly what
a stupid [ __ ] are and Bulger and all
these [ __ ] places would be like oh
this was the most brilliant finally a
stand-up with a voice you could take any
speech and it's like take a Hitler
speech it'd be like you know you know it
wasn't Hitler was killing it
he was killing it at one speed it's like
come on man that did what except she
didn't get the same response but it's
like M night Shyamalan made a movie
called the village he made a really good
movie I loved it
horribly received because he gave a good
movie but advertised a horror movie yeah
so all these horror buff movie come
movie fans come out they're like oh it's
gonna be this great scary horror film
and what they got instead was a really
great movie yeah fun twist wasn't scary
right so they leave going what the [ __ ]
was that there's no monsters yeah we
wanted monsters you know and so um no
dead ghosts
yep if they would have just said oh this
is like a thinking movie like it would
have been like it would want Awards I
think it was such a good movie but the
problem is they advertised it like it
was gonna be
Krampus or something and you didn't get
that and that's what kind of Nanette did
she gave a really great thing that
liberals loved in any lesbian with an
article in a blog freken went crazy
about but she didn't give us stand up
I wanted stand up in a now cuz she's
very talented give me more of the
stoplight humor that's what I like from
you Internet yeah it was yeah I totally
agree yeah and that and I think that
what we're trying to balance and in the
entertainment society right now is to
try to find out remembering that it's
called the entertainment [ __ ]
absolutely you know when I think that
like I've never want a new early maccer
I never wanted to be like real political
or like talk about these kind of things
I just had no interest but it's also
because maybe I wasn't there yet
you know you were so I didn't that
doesn't you for sure weren't there you
know you know you weren't there and then
you're just like I say I feel you cuz
how are you know I'm 36 now well that's
what it is yeah you turned 35 when men
turns 35 is when we go oh [ __ ] I gotta
get a real job
it's Whistler's you start to go I gotta
put money in the bank and like you know
you started chain that's me that's when
we grew unfortunately when we become
like that when we start being a
grown-ass man it'd be snowboarding don't
break my leg you start a mortgage you're
welcome to being a grown-ass man you
know I mean welcome to this side of it
you know what I mean so and then it 40
is gonna hit and that's what you're
really gonna get into your groove yeah
I'm ready
I'm ready for read he is ready but
ladies and gentlemen I want to thank you
for watching please subscribe and share
I'll have all of Jeff's info underneath
he has a great podcast which is called
Jeff dies friendship podcast Jeff guys
friendship podcast and are you doing the
show with Terry brown on them again no
that's done it was great yeah two
seasons is still on Hulu and stuff like
that I gots a bunch of projects coming
out later this year it'll be great
alright so yeah anyway I'll have this
like website information all that stuff
you can find Jeff on there and you know
I'm gonna go on his podcast and I'll
have him I like having repeat guests cuz
I just like talking to my friends
because especially when it comes to my
place I've had a lot of weird requests
like this I was on seals podcast we were
talking about guns and stuff yeah so
this like Republican this guy hits me up
he goes hey I'm an ex-cop I'm white I'm
a conservative and I want to come debate
you on your podcast about the Hebrews
and I was like sounds interesting but at
the same time I was like I don't know if
I want a [ __ ] like that come
with me yes we knows introduced like a
pill burbles like you're studios in your
house and it's like yes I built a you
know I home here but that's part of it I
want you to know you're in my house yeah
I get better things out of people
sometimes so much good things that they
go hey can you bed at that part I
question in there I probably like that
because they're drinking out of my glass
I bring them into my kitchen I say where
this from my fridge and we go upstairs
and and we we get a little comfy before
we record and and so that there's
something to that you're gonna get more
real out of people but the bad side is
you don't want some yeah crazy person is
like I used to be on a TV show in 1985
who are you that's why mine's a
friendship vodka oh I like again maybe I
need to but mine's just call riff it
with Griffin so we just riff with
Griffin to be like you know I mean yeah
so it is what it is but anyways we can't
even think of us good buddies we can't
even say goodbye but this has been Jeff
died this is Griffin with Griffin like I
said please subscribe and share I
appreciate you guys watching as always
I'm sure all the trolls will be in the
comments cuz we hit a lot of fun topics
together I love it so see you guys next
week